Hey everyone,
jared,
I possibly rl here and today we're
questioning the nature of our reality
season two of westworld premiere this
week and it got some pretty mixed
reactions,
but hopefully it's just setting the
stage for great stuff to come.
Today I want to talk about the biggest
question the premiere raises.
Is there any difference between humans
and flesh box?
And the biggest clue I'm going to argue
is right here in the intro.
Welcome this wisecrack quick take on
season two,
episode one of Westworld and spoilage.
First a quick recap.
In the aftermath of Ford's ranger over
retirement party,
Bernard Poles and inception and wakes up
disoriented on a beach.
Bernard joins.
Dalio is head of operations Karl Strand
as they hunt down the rest of the
malfunctioning hosts.
But in the meantime,
we see flashbacks of Bernard weeks
earlier trying to survive the parties.
Immediate aftermath.
Hail Brings Bernard two or secret lab
where they Zuckerberg everything by
secretly harvesting the guest personal
information and DNA stubs stranded.
Bernard find that all the hosts are
floating in a body of water that
shouldn't exist and Bernard reveals that
he killed them.
Count.
Meanwhile,
Mavis still trying to find her daughter
and as enlisted the help of this use of
the city.
Yet delores and teddy are on a straight
up murder spree and Dolores has a new
hobby recycling lines from season one in
rapid succession.
He's five ft lights just like anything
to me
later.
She suggests they take the fun to the
humans on the mainland and William is
having a grand old time trying not to
die before we're getting introduced to
the mazes.
Much anticipated sequel,
the door
have to make it back out the door.
What does it mean?
Well,
we're going to have to keep watching to
find out now.
There seems to be too important phrases
that we should keep in mind as the
season progresses.
The first is free and the second is what
is real,
which is irreplaceable.
Let's start with the first,
since season one,
westworld has teased the idea that we're
not all that different from the host
humans fancy that there's something
special about the way we perceive the
world and yet we live in newbs as tight
and as close to as the host.
Seldom questioning choices contend for
the most part to be told what to do
next.
Hosts are guided by their programming.
That's pretty obvious,
but this episode goes to great lengths
to invert our understanding of the
nature of that program.
Previously,
we learned that the host had specific
drives.
What are your,
I tend to my herd,
look after my wife
and now dolores is asking the park's
guess what their drives are.
What are your drives please?
I don't want to die.
The basic survival instinct is likened
to the cornerstone
survival.
Sure.
Cornerstone
or the foundational memories that define
hosts like mave or Bernard backstories
do more than amuse guests.
They anchor the host.
It's their cornerstone just as the
hosts,
our program with certain instincts,
so too are the humans evolutionarily
program to pursue survival above all
else.
This idea that humans are primarily
guided by their survival instinct is
really driven home by this
juxtaposition.
Charlotte Hale tells Bernard hosts only
do what they're programmed to do.
They do with their program,
and immediately a delose board member
runs for what he thinks will save his
life.
Some lab techs with the vehicle.
Of course it was a trap.
The host took advantage of the guest
basic survival instincts or to put
another way they're programming.
Okay,
so humans don't like to die.
That's not exactly,
I'm just a machine one on one,
but it's with mave that things get
really interesting.
Maybe it's one of the few hosts who has
actually seen her programming.
Not only that,
she knows someone manipulated her code,
so she would escape the park and recruit
her fellow hosts,
but she nonetheless tries to navigate
what free will means when it seems all
of her choices are predestined at the
end of season one.
There's a kind of paradox in that she
must choose between two things she was
programmed to do while on the train.
She can escape the park as this
mysterious code change wants or to or go
back to her fake daughter if it was
ambiguous before mave stance on what is
real is made abundantly clear when
sizemore tells her that her daughter
isn't really hers,
it's just a story.
Somebody we programmed,
she's not real.
But instead of rejecting this fiction,
she says,
all right,
what about me?
My dreams,
my thoughts,
my body?
And they don't know.
What if I took these fingers?
Don't use them to decorate the walls
with your outsize personality.
Would that
be real?
Rather than getting tripped up about
what is really real may for search her
own reality.
So what does it mean to embrace
something,
even though it's a fiction?
Westworld here asserts a radical
skepticism toward what is really real,
especially as far as humanity is
concerned.
The fact that Mavis searching for her
daughter is no accident.
The show is overtly using maternal
instincts to argue that humans are no
less dictated by code then hosts.
It's why they threw a baby with its
mother into the new intro for humans.
Maternal care is strongly associated
with a kind of biological coding.
You and mother's care for their young
and let them live a parasitic existence
for the next 1825 years of their life
because their genes tell them to.
And while we see similar behavior in
chimps,
the same can't be said for other animals
who exhibit different biologically coded
ways to relate to their young bears
abandoned.
They're young.
If they're too weak,
harp seals ditch them after 12 days to
find another mate cuckoos trick other
animals into doing their dirty work and
some spiders just go ahead and let their
babies eat them alive.
It's called [inaudible] and it's so in
math,
but the point is can we really call
naves relationship to her daughter fake
when we as humans are reared by an adult
woman because her genes tell her to
coddle us instead of dumbass onto the
neighbor's lawn and that's the real
meaning of the boy Ford's words.
Everything in here is code William,
the host and it's human guests are
bounded by their programming,
whether it be genetic or artificial into
further muddy the waters of this real
versus fake distinction.
Let's turn back to burn Arnold's words
that what is real is what is
irreplaceable.
If that's true,
then Arnold's not real because he was
replaced by Bernard and there's a whole
room full of Bernard's we've seen in
this trailer.
And if Arnold can get replaced by a
host,
can we all,
there's one more phrase,
all motors
function.
Now there's one more thing on my mind.
When Bernard taps into the Mesh Network,
he troubleshoots his own malfunction and
we get a list of everything wrong with
him.
Lapse in time.
And this big word prosopagnosia turns
out this means face blindness and could
potentially explain why the hell burn
artists fixated on this corpse.
But to hear more about that,
along with a deep dive into what is
real,
be sure to check out the maze wise
cracks,
westworld podcast.
You can click the link in the
description or find it on itunes,
stitcher,
soundcloud,
or any of that jazz.
As always,
thank you guys for watching peace.
Okay.